et cet homme est mon prisonnier
ton père et moi avons travaillé ensemble
c'était fait pas mal d'ennemis il était
sur un gros coup une prime importante ce
que vous êtes dangereux pas pour mes
amis c'est dommage parce que j'ai
suffisamment d'amis
elle gringo narco le plus grand
trafiquant de maître du Midwest et fera
demain une plaque tournante de la drogue
désormais
les se réaliseront
j'ai un conseil si j'étais toi je
partirai je reviendrai jamais alors on
se met au travail ou pas
au travail
on a peur de l'accusation grâce à la
gare de mes potes il a beaucoup
d'influence sur cette île ne doute plus
jamais de moi
vous croyez qu'il va se noyer si on a de
la chance
sois mort avant qu'il quitte la
propriété
est-ce que vous attendez Noël
tu es trop stupide pour mourir tu m'as
pour chassé pendant 10 ans je suis
accessible compulsif